[Applause]
thank you very much Debbie our student
speaker today is one of 129 students
from 30 countries and 75 universities
chosen this academic year as a
Schwartzman scholar today Krystal Thomas
earns her bachelor's degree in
biological sciences from Carnegie Mellon
University's Mellon College of Science
Krystal has been an active member of the
Carnegie Mellon community serving as
founding president of colors at CMU a
student organization that promotes open
conversations on race and diversity she
served as one of the inaugural members
of the diversity and inclusion
roundtable and is a mentor in the
coaching minority progress and
successful science program she is a past
president of the Gates Millennium
Scholarship from the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and is an Andrew
Carnegie Society college scholar a
distinction bestowed upon only 40
graduating seniors the daughter of a
Haitian immigrants Krystle plans to
complete a master of global affairs with
a concentration in public policy at
Tsinghua University in Beijing China and
work to address barriers to healthcare
faced by immigrant families it was a
great pleasure for me this morning to
meet crystals parents crystal I would
like to now invite you to the 40
[Applause]
five years ago I came to CMU as a high
school student I was here for the
university's summer academy of math and
science or stands for short now I didn't
know the Carnegie Mellon or that Sam's
excuse me
or the program for minority students and
the entire time I was surrounded by
people who look like me so I left
thinking this is great
Carnegie Mellon University a
historically black college for math and
science right I'm Paula going here even
though CMU wasn't exactly what I
expected I'm so so glad I decided to
come here I have learned so much or here
at Carnegie Mellon and not just
academically problem-solving had a whole
difficult conversations and most
importantly I now know there's so so
much more that I don't know what drives
people how do our environments influence
us how is our world interconnected I've
started to think about these questions
because I've been fortunate enough to
meet many of you in getting to know your
stories your perspective and the way you
think about things I didn't phone away
as someone who came from a town where
high school students that they couldn't
go to college if they didn't have the
money as someone whose pediatrician told
her at least one of us made out of this
worthless place as someone whose
relative told her
is it Carnegie Mellon a bit too advanced
for you I am immensely proud to be a
part of this campus I am so proud to be
able to offer you today what now we're
about to leave the CMU bubble some of us
may start working and receive nice
paychecks some of us may go on to
graduate school and receive alright
paychecks and some of us may take a
well-deserved break
what's then instead of thinking about
the next achievement now is our
opportunity to reflect on purpose as we
and enter the next stage of our life
purpose the reason we exist may be
Carnegie Mellon has already helped you
find your purpose maybe you're just
getting started we should reflect on
purpose because it develops us keeps us
resilient and can lead us to happiness
so how do we crystallize purpose or even
find purpose in the first place
we help others
we are driven by the need to impact
others we're social animals after all
I'm a biology major trust me so what's
the relationship between purpose helping
others and happiness well to me there
are three levels of happiness first you
can gain happiness from simply building
something then there's the second level
of happiness when people praised what
you have built and as if there's a third
level of happiness when someone tells
you what you have built has changed my
life that level of happiness just can't
be beat in the past that makes you feel
the most fulfilled the past that gives
you the greatest happiness can give you
insight on purpose we've already been
practicing impacting the lives of others
we've overloaded become execs on board
volunteered for a thousand plus 238
research strives because CMU is a
striving place we're a bunch of
overachievers who've been presented with
so many opportunities and have been
encouraged to learn now is our time to
put practice into action continue to
strive continue to aspire and as you
leave here today send your life around
purpose Center your life around
impacting others that purpose guide you
and to everyone who helped us along the
way
mentors who have guided us throughout
the process
faculty members who helped us see just
what we could do and loved ones who have
been with us and encouraged us every
step of the way
thank you and thank you class of 2017 I
know you will do great things
thank you thank you crystal